okay so the topic of this video is going
to be the genetic inheritance pattern
known as incomplete and codominance
we're going to do two patterns at once
and you'll see the two patterns have
some features in common with one another
but also some key differences so let's
go ahead and get started so let's first
look at the inheritance pattern called
codominance and the definition of
codominance is when a single gene has
more than one dominant allele that if
you've seen my other videos before we've
never seen this pattern before and this
was this is this was completely unknown
to Gregor Mendel as well if you recall
from Mendel's experiments you know he
was looking at for instance flower color
the peas either had purple flowers or
white flowers purple was dominant white
was recessive but in the codominance
it's possible to have more than one
dominant allele and for instance an
example is in the cattle coat or the fur
of cattle for instance in the picture we
have a an individual with red fur and an
individual with white fur now when you
look at the red cow and the white cow if
they were to breed and reproduce with
one another what all the babies come out
pink that'd be adorable if that was true
but know that that's a myth that's not
what happens so what does happen in
codominance watch this what we see is a
pattern the reality where both colors
are equally expressed you see like
patches are red and you see patches of
white and we call this color pattern
here roan so Reds not dominant what's
not I should say red is not dominant to
white and white is not dominant to red
they are equally dominant you see both
at the same time a good example of
codominance in humans
is in blood types you know you might
have heard of different types of blood
like blood type A blood type B well when
we look at blood types you know well
here's a red blood cell and blood type a
has these proteins on it now the
proteins are not actually shaped like
English letter A's and be a little
simplistic here but blood type A has
some proteins on the surface
blood type B has different kinds of
proteins on the surface so what happens
if mom was blood type A what happens if
dad was blood type B if the MA if mom
and dad were to produce a child for
instance the two blood types would be
codominant the child or the offspring
that was born would have characteristics
of both blood type A and blood type B so
we're gonna go into this in a little
more detail so let's talk about blood
types now when it comes to blood types
there are three alleles and this is
something that we haven't seen before
when Mendel was studying his pea plants
for instance he was studying the gene
for flower color there are only two
alleles flower colors are either purple
or white when Mendel was examining the
gene for for seed color the seeds were
either green or yellow there was never a
third option but in blood types there
are there's an A allele which happens to
be dominant there's a B allele which
also happens to be dominant and there's
an O allele which is recessive now when
we look at the picture on the right hand
side you see the box that said mom will
pass one of these three alleles onto her
offspring maybe mom has Type A maybe she
has type B maybe a she has type O but
either way mom is gonna pass on one of
these three alleles to her child
on the top of the picture dad is gonna
pass on one of these three alleles to
the child so when you look at the what
are the what are the possible genotypes
that a child can have when mom and dad
have a baby with regards to blood type
these are the nine options and when we
start going through the blood types a to
capital A's that's type-a blood 1 a and
1 B that's codominant that's codominant
type a B blood the next one to the right
dominant a and a recessive
oh that's blood type a a is dominant oh
is recessive when we look at this the
middle row if you inherit one dominant a
and one dominant B
that's blood type a B the next box to
the right if you inherit two B alleles
your blood type will be type B the next
one to the right if you inherit one B
from the payoff from mom and one Oh from
dad blood type you'll have blood type B
again B is dominant oh is recessive and
finally the bottom layer are the bottom
row of this table here if you inherit a
dominant a from one parent and a
recessive o from the other you'll have
blood type a on type a is dominant by
type o is recessive same with blood type
B B is dominant o is recessive so the
only way you can have type O blood is if
you inherit not one Oh leo
but two Oh alleles so what we learned
from looking at blood types is that
blood type A and B are dominant two
blood type O blood type O is recessive
so therefore the only way to have blood
type a B is if you inherit a dominant a
and a dominant B they are codominant
they are equally dominant if you inherit
one A and one B a does not cover up B
and B does not cover up a they're
equally dominant to one another so if we
were doing this in class I did give you
guys from time but you know right now as
you're watching this video you know read
this story Mike is heterozygous for Type
A Lisa's heterozygous with Type B try to
set up a punnett square
pause the video right now pause the
video try to answer these questions I'm
gonna go over the answers in three two
one
so first of all if I say Mike is
heterozygous for Type A or there's the
genotype one capital A one recessive oh
that's what it means to be heterozygous
if Lisa's heterozygous for type B blood
she's gonna have one dominant B allele
and a recessive allele so now when I do
the punnett square I just have to fill
in the A's the O's
in the O's and these are my results I
can look at question a what is the
problem
probability of having a child with type
A blood according to this situation
probability is 25% look at question D
what is the probability of having a
child with codominant blood well that
answer is also 25% and you can see the
the the part of the punnett square that
I've highlighted is the codominant
option and then question see what's the
probability of having a child that's
heterozygous in this case there's a 75%
chance I have in a heterozygous child
member heterozygous is a different
combination of alleles and so there's
three out of four right there try this
one
Jason is homozygous for type A blood and
Maria's heterozygous for type B blood
their child rick has codominant blood
you know pause the video and try to draw
a pedigree try to complete a B and C I'm
gonna go over the answers in three two
one
so first of all I'm gonna try to draw a
pedigree for this family Jason is a
square Maria is a circle squares for men
circles for women and it says the story
says they have a child Rick Rick is a
boy's name so I'm going to use a square
for Rick
now the story says that Jason the father
has type A blood
now there's two options for type A blood
either capital a capital A which is
homozygous or capital a lowercase O
which is heterozygous now the story says
he's homozygous so I know jason has to
be capital a capital A what about Maria
the mom Maria has type B blood now
there's two ways to have type B blood
you can either be homozygous capital B
capital B or heterozygous capital B
lowercase O the story says Maria's
heterozygous so I know she has to be
capital B lowercase o and it says
they're child
rick has codominant point what the heck
does that mean what does it mean to have
codominant blood what it means is that
you have one dominant a
and one dominant B allele so now that
I've drawn the pedigree question a I can
move on to question B complete a punnett
square for Jason and Maria y know Jason
is capital a capital A and I know Maria
is capital B lowercase O so when I fill
in the punnett square this is what it
should look like right here and so I've
now completed question B now I can look
at question C well the story says rick
has Co dominant bud but what were the
odds of that happening from the punnett
square you can see the odds of that
happening were 50% so let's move on to
the next part of this so how does
codominant differ from what we call
incomplete dominance well before we go
into incomplete dominance let's take a
moment to review what member was
studying when he was looking at the
flower color of of pea plants you know
he had a pea bred purple flowers with
white flowers and when he did the purple
flower would count would pass on a
dominant purple allele and when he bred
this situation the white parent would
pass on a recessive white allele and so
when he bred his his pea plants like
this purple crossed with white a hundred
percent 100 percent of his flowers grew
purple flowers and this is because
Mendel figured out that purple must be
dominant to white Mendel uncovered the
genetics pattern called autosomal
recessive white is recessive purple was
dominant so we haven't seen any other
type of example other than what we see
right here but incomplete dominance is
very different watch this with
incomplete dominance neither allele is
completely dominant so for instance
heterozygous individuals blend their
appearance for instance if one parent
was red and one parent was white when
they reproduce and make offspring the
heterozygous offspring would be
pink in this case blended red and white
blend to make pink we have we haven't
seen this option before so this explains
why some genes can have there can be
more than two phenotypes we've never
seen that before there are only two
phenotypes possible when Mendel was
studying his pea plants the flowers were
either purple or white there was never a
third option so this explains why many
flower colors why many flowers I should
say that exhibit more than just two
colors you look at all the colors of
roses all the different colors of
carnations because of incomplete
dominance so here we have a practice
problem now as certain species of fish
blue scales capital B capital B and
yellow scales capital y capital wire
incomplete dominant fill in the punnett
square for a genotype of a blue male and
a green female you know try to do the
punnett square and answer these two
questions I'm gonna put I want you to
pause the video and try to do it
yourself I'm gonna go over the answers
in 3 2 1
well if you had a hard time getting
started maybe it helps to just make a
key so in the story you're told that
capital B capital B is blue capital y
Capital y is yellow but the question
says one of the parents the female is
green does that mean we use capital G
capital G for green no remind yourself
what yellow and blue mix to make yellow
and blue mix to make green Green is a
blended mix of blue and yellow so for
that reason you'll use B and Y so now
you can set up your punnett square a
blue male capital B capital B a green
female capital B capital y now you can
fill in the punnett square and if I were
to ask you in the top left hand corner
what color would that fish be only
capital D's it'd be blue top right
corner and B green lower left corner
blue the lower right-hand corner in D
green so
question a what is the probability of
obtaining a heterozygous fish I hope you
see the answer is 50% heterozygous means
a different combination of alleles
how about question B what's the
probability of growing a yellow fish
it's not possible in this punnett square
in this punnett square it's only
possible to produce blue or green fish
yellow is not possible so here's another
practice problem carnations showing
complete dominance where red allele were
readily on white allele blend to make
pink that's a very important sentence a
pink colored male pollinated a pink
colored female so both parents are pink
7 seeds were created the seeds were
planted and they later grew in the
plants with 3 having pink flowers 2 with
white flowers and 2 with red flowers so
pause the video pause the video and try
to complete a B and C I'm going to go
over the answers in 3 2 1
so the first thing I'm going to have you
do is create a pedigree for the nine
individuals the two parents and the
seven offspring so again maybe make a
key it's a good way to get started we're
to capital ours would represent red to
capital w's would represent white so are
you going to use to capital peas for
pink no I hope not for pink remind
yourself what pink is pink is a mixture
of our four red and W for white so
you're told in the story that both
parents are pink and that they produce
seven seeds of the seven seeds three
have pink flowers and two have white
flowers and two have red flowers so
we're on our way to filling out this
Punnett Square and the pedigree here so
the story also says both in on both
parents a pink colored male pollinated a
pink colored female both parents are
pink RW from both parents well now I can
set up my punnett square because now I
know the genotype of both parents so
when I set up the punnett square and
then I fill in the
hours and they fill in the W's I hope
you see what we have here there's a one
out of four chance the seeds would have
grown to have red petals there's a two
out of four chance that the seeds would
have grown to have pink petals and
there's a one out of four chance that
the seeds would have grown to have white
petals so you were gonna if you were
gonna fill in the probability of your
question see the answer to Question C
what is the probability of growing pink
from the punnett square you can see the
answer is 2 out of 4 or 50% you also can
now figure out the genotype of all seven
offspring all the three pink ones have
to be ours and w's the two white ones
have to be W's and the two Reds have to
be ours
so there you go there's a fairly lengthy
story problem there that you can
complete on incomplete dominance so just
to sum up this video look at these two
pictures which is which which flower
shows incomplete dominance which flower
shows codominance so pause the video if
you need some time to think about it I'm
going to show the answers in three two
one
did you get it correct on the left the
pink flower is where they blend and
that's incomplete dominance on the right
is where you see both colors at the same
time and you can see red and white
petals at the same time that's called
codominance so that's the end of this
video I hope you found it helpful for
reviewing and understanding the
difference between codominance and
incomplete dominance